[Music]
my name is
nick schrock my name uh and i'm the
founder of elemental
and that's it's a company behind dagster
and so what i want to talk about today
is kind of introducing what dagster
is but in the context of we what we like
to call the full data application
lifecycle
so we're going to talk about the premise
for the project and then
also show kind of how you know different
phases of an application progress how
dicer can support a full
life cycle so what is
dexter dagster is a data orchestrator
um you know and we just started recently
calling ourselves a data orchestrator in
public
as in literally five seconds ago we're
about to kind of uh re-title what the
project is so
you heard it here you heard it here
first folks
um but why do we call it the data
orchestrator what
what's in a name um well we want to be
clear about what we are
and what our unique vision is in this uh
sector
so first of all we're an orchestrator
our job is to manage and orchestrate
the graph of computations that comprise
what we like to call data applications
and i'll go into that term
in a second um data applications week
yeah we effectively view ml pipelines
etl elt et cetera as effectively the
instances of the same software problem
next we are metadata and data aware
and we think this is kind of like our
you know what really distinguishes us
from adjacent systems in this space
which are generally
agnostic to the data flowing through
their systems
and just about the computations and
managing dependency order
we also have a much more opinionated
programming model
which allows us to build much more rich
tooling
and then lastly i just want to emphasize
that you know just philosophically this
system we orchestrate data we relate
data and computations but we also firmly
believe
that the data space is very
heterogeneous and will continue to be
heterogeneous over time
and increasingly so actually i mean like
there's just so many new computational
run times and there's
ones that pop up every day and there's
new infrastructure new cloud providers
et cetera et cetera
so we're committed to supporting the
applications that are on any runtime
i.e like spark data warehouses any
compute environment whether it be
serverless or kubernetes
any storage whether it's like file
systems s3 and whatnot
we're agnostic to those concerns so
let's talk about this data application
concept
so we define a data application as a
graph of functional computations
that produce and consume data assets in
the end that's what we're all trying to
do here
we're taking files we're doing
computation on them
we're producing databases database
tables or something
um so if you kind of google around right
look for the more familiar
terms in the space you have stuff like
ml pipelines and this is literally the
images i found when i googled around
um and you have like the sequence of
steps where you start with a file you
end up with a model that is being served
or you have like a classic you know if
you look for etl you get some real
graphic design
uh monstrosities there and this is a
classic of ingesting
you know csv and using set and awk to a
multi-threaded java
process which i've found quite charming
and then there's kind of the more modern
du jour
elt uh stage which is effectively etl
except extend
instead you just persist the raw data
before you process it right and
effectively
most modern systems just kind of do this
as a matter of course these days
and so what's interesting about this is
that we think these are all
fundamentally the same systems
right they're all these kind of like
data factories that consume data and
like flow it through
they're all graphs of functions at the
core that's what they do
yeah i had to insert this slide after
last week's
talks where literally four out of four
of the presentations
all put up this slide so i want to keep
that streak alive
but it's actually very germane because
like if people ml people
sometimes hear this and like wait i
don't do etl that's that's someone
else's job
but probably the most like famous
graphic in
ml explains how all of the work is
everything which isn't
which isn't ml right if you take out
serving infrastructure and ml code
in this chart you're basically left with
what hitherto has been known as
etl right data processes the core of all
these systems
the other thing is interesting is these
things actually end up interrelate right
you might be in a team
or set of teams where like one team runs
the etl pipeline they produce some data
assets that then the ml people produce
downstream
so by artificially siloing these pieces
of software you actually
compartmentalize a system which
should actually be treated like one
logical system
okay so what are the properties of these
things
well i can say they're multi right it's
a very heterogeneous world
multi-persona they're logical systems
that people is varied of analysts data
scientists and data engineers interact
with
their multi-tool each one of those
people i mentioned
has very different cultures they have
very different skill sets they use very
different tools they have different
preferences
you have to go to where the people are
you can't
force everyone to encode their business
logic in one system
it's also multi-team just kind of like
gets more and more complicated
right these systems span the entire
enterprise need to subdivide
the application of the teams and then as
a result those teams often end up
running their own environments
right um and it's just like an extremely
extremely complicated domain
the last thing to say is that this is
software engineering
um and what i mean by that is that a lot
of times traditionally especially when
you're talking about the etl term
the the move has been to try to like
move
kind of analysts or people who aren't
engineers
into a gui tool that they're comfortable
with and get them to do engineering
tasks in a non-engineering way
we at dexter finally don't believe
that's how the world works
um you know one example of this that i
love is a project that i'm a huge fan of
which is dbt
which has taken analysts and instead of
trying to like
jam them into a gui and say you don't
have to be an engineer
they say no here's a tool that makes
sense to you that makes you into an
engineer
and you know this data is a software
engineering discipline
it needs tools that acknowledge the
complexity of that
and embrace it all right so
let's talk about the the data
application life cycle
so another one of our beliefs is that
this core orchestrator which is the
thing that knows about everything in the
system
right it knows like the orchestrator a
data where orchestrator can know about
every single runtime that interacts in
the data application
every single piece of data that gets
produced every single piece of data gets
consumed it's kind of the fundamental
structure of this thing
and we think that this graph the the
computational graph of the data
application models
should be involved and support every
stage of the software life cycle
so you should be fundamentally using the
same tools to both
locally develop on your laptop to some
degree
locally developing your laptop to
operating this thing in a cluster
so let's talk about develop here
so we're going to do one of these
classic like toy examples right
where we're going to load some data data
frame
into pandas we're going to take that
data frame and augment it with call it a
feature
that's what sugar's for cup is we're
going to compute
something based on that feature and then
do some business logic
so all we do here is we find like the
top 25 of cereals
uh based on sugarcoat per cup we compute
the 75
cut off and then we filter everything
and then we write it back to a csv file
right classic blinking lights demo so
this
is just a raw python script that does
that
right and for those of you who've done
it this is pandas it's a
like very well known uh data processing
library
and um and yeah so it's just like basic
code
so now what we want to do is we want to
make this
into a dexter pipeline um
so you hip and soledax or this is an
open source python project
and what you do is you can start kind of
like you know sprinkling these magic
decorators on your existing python code
um so here all we do is we add we call
our unit and we'll go and do the second
we'll call our kind of like node in our
graph a solid
and we annotate it with a solid and then
we add this first parameter which you
can go into later
and then to orchestrate this thing you
just kind of like naturally call python
code
but it this actually constructs a
representation of the debt
of the computation rather than executing
it
eagerly so the same before we have the
solid
we call it like a functional unit of
computation in the orchestration graph
in the end it's just a function with
some specific semantics
that that framework knows how to
interact with and it's specifically
designed
for reuse for testability and i hope i
can show you those features as we go
more
and then we have a pipeline which is a
graph of solids i think the thing to
note here
is that we are connected via data
dependencies
so for example if you look at filter
below cutoff
it has like a serials input which is
represents a data frame and you have to
you know route that from a previous
computation which outputted a data frame
so we you know encourage the user
to encode their data dependencies in
this way and we think this leads to much
more reliable
far more testable systems so
once you do that you can pip install our
front end tool called
daggett and then effectively point
daggett to this thing and this is
running on our laptop and so now
i can demo
let me share my screen here all right
i'm just going to assume everyone can
see this
and if we hop here so this is what the
you know this is what the gui looks like
when we're just looking at this thing
so we have a representation in this web
app
you'll notice that we have data
dependencies note how we have the any
type
anywhere we kind of like automatically
assign the any type
so that um so that ends up being gradual
and optional and now
so we can view this and we can also
execute it
right and so i'm actually going to
configure this thing to run each of the
steps in its own process and this is
actually here
live on my laptop this is actually kind
of terrifying because
the computational expense of might
totally shut this thing down
and
that is definitely going to happen oh
it's just really slow isn't it
so same before you know going back to
this definition thing
we have you know this dag here and now
just locally right we can just execute
this thing
so we go
and so this is this beautiful kind of
gantt chart viewer that we have which
live updates and like i don't know how
good it ends up looking over zoom but
it's it's very pleasant to use i'll give
you that we have logging
we have all this stuff you know one
interesting thing is that one of the
things the system is doing
is it's automatically managing kind of
shuffling the intermediate values from
one node
in that my case on my laptop is just to
process the machine to another
this allows us to do things like okay we
can just select this node which is this
one thing
we can see a log message is happening we
can just like re-execute that step
right so by even just this like minimal
decoration
of all these kind of functions you get
like
a ton of capabilities uh right outside
the box you can see we actually like
link retries versus run lineage and
group them together
uh these end up being views in a run
viewer you can see all this information
you can go back to the run so it really
is a joy to use
okay so we have you know
nice demo nice ui has some interesting
capabilities
but you know we haven't really done that
so much interesting yet
and so i'm going to take this one second
year there's this classic
you know what's the next problem we want
to deal with well there's this classic
you know line about a founders fund
which is like we wanted
flying cars we got 140 characters right
but this was like 10 years ago i think
the slogan needs updating
and i would suggest in 2020
the right answer would be this which is
we got 100
we wanted flying cars we have yaml
oh my god do we have yaml i mean
everyone talks about yeah with
kubernetes
and this like this like cambrian
explosion of yaml but it's equally bad
not bad it's equally it is what it is in
the data application space
um and you know
just a huge amount of apple a huge
amount of configuration
goes into any sort of internal platform
of
any sort of significance there's just
like yaml xml
json all over the place it's often
undocumented
and it's doubly worse because it's
frequently the interface
between leaf developers and the
infrastructure developers
so we thought and in our approach for
testability we were probably going to
make configuration
more complicated so we thought we need
to build software abstractions and
manage that so we have a configuration
system
now go over this quickly but what it
effectively is
is schema over python dictionaries um
it's self-describing it gives these high
quality error messages
which is pretty critical so you can look
at it you can have a really good idea
what the configuration is supposed to be
if you screw it up it gives you very
clear error messages
you catch errors earlier in the process
and you have an auto completing yaml
editor which is really nice
so just to demo this very quickly um you
know
i wanted to figure out how to demo the
config system like well i would actually
like to well this is before the um
thing slowed down my computer but i
wanted to inject computational delays
uh into this uh into this demo
to demo the gantt chart better i'm like
okay why don't we use the
why don't we use the you know this
config editor to do that so
we go there and instead we oh
switch right in here that's faster
go the next step in the demo you'll see
here
you have like this config right here and
then you can go to the playground here
and i preloaded some config but let's
pretend like we hadn't typed that
and now you can see on the right hand
side you have the schema right there
about how you can configure this thing
and we can say actually i want to delay
this
actually let me show you see how the
documentation is right in there
so nice um so now we can do this and we
can launch it
and now you'll see that like we have
been able to configure
this delay um
uh configure this delay the next one
should be a lot slower
um boom there we go um so you're able to
like
you know you're able to adorn
different artifacts in our system with
config it's self-describing it can be
very complicated and dusty and you get
all this tooling support around it
uh we think it's actually really
critical
next we have our type system so you
notice
in the previous demo that all the
connections between the nodes were
annotated with the any type
um that's because we have a type system
it has to have a type and the way we
make this thing gradual and optional so
you can like kind of like opt
into it is by defaulting everything to
any
we think that's really important
especially because the nature of these
systems
is that often you don't know what the
data you're dealing with is
until you start writing the computation
so the dynamic
you want is you want to be able to kind
of be writing the code
and having it in the system and then as
you figure stuff out about the data
you're processing you can kind of like
augment the type system to reflect your
current level of insight into the data
and the other thing is that our type
system is very arbitrary
meaning that a user defined type its
core
kind of property is a function that the
user writes to determine whether or not
the type check
pass this leaves our users to have
enormous flexibility
about what these types represent so
you know if we edited the code here
to reflect the types you'll notice that
we import a data frame type from one of
our
libraries called dexter pandas and we
can annotate this function with types
this automatically gets ingested and we
kind of interpret it
as daxter types and that that thing that
we imported is not like a python type
it's actually like constructed with our
api
and has all these different properties
and i don't have time to go into all the
different properties of it but we can
attach all sorts of behavior to it so
you'll see here that the dag here now is
kind of
decorated right with you know the fact
that like it takes this type it spits
out this type etc
it's great for documentation you know
and
you can like trust it more and you know
what this gets to a world
where we were you want to get to as a
dexter developer is you want your solids
to
kind of describe themselves you want to
look at this and understand exactly
what the state of the world is necessary
for this computation to complete
so in this case and we'll build this up
over time but add sugar per cup says
like hey
if i have access to a data frame i'll do
computation on it and spit out a data
frame
that's like my contract with the world
um
[Music]
so um you know one interesting thing is
that now this data
isn't coming from anywhere um and so you
might be thinking where does that come
from and one of the behaviors that we
have is you can actually
specify where to source data for types
from config
so the moment that you do this you can
go to the next demo
here and so
we have this dag right you have this
data frame type and you click on here
it says it's like there's just all this
gobbledygook over here
and what that means is that you can
actually specify
via config and this whole config schema
and the behavior around it is totally
customized
um uh customizable by the user you know
so if this was commented out
but but effectively what you can say is
like hey actually for this thing
execute and load directly to csv the
user doesn't have to write that code
and that gets incredibly useful once you
start talking about executing subsets of
these things
so here i'm not going to go into it but
you can like select sub strokes of this
dag and execute them
and then use that type system to load to
parameterize those computations
okay
so let's talk about testing so we've
talked about development
right we've kind of annotated a
relatively simple pipeline with the
dijkstra primitives
we've we have this kind of a really nice
local ide experience you can retry you
have a nice developer workflow
um but now let's talk about testing so a
couple words on testing
one testing data applications is
uniquely challenging
um and you know it's a combination of
things
one is like often the data is really big
you don't have control
over the input data so you're thrashed
in production a lot
uh often these data applications have
very heavy external dependency on
unmockable things like data warehouses
and smart clusters
so testing is a challenge and the issue
with that
is that the status quo is kind of like
if you think about all the stages where
you can catch
defects in software in data world
it's way lopsided towards prod
and you know how bad that is right
because defects that are caught in prod
a bug showing up in a ceo dashboard is
way worse than one showing up at a test
suite
right it's kind of like obviously true
and
you know our goal is not to say like
everything has to be 100
testable we want to be clear that we
want to be practical on this our goal is
to bend this curve
there's still with the nature of these
systems you cannot change them there is
some testing that can only happen in
production
right performance testing to some degree
like you're only able to catch changing
prod data in prod
it's just the nature of the beast but
what we want to do is be able to move
testing farther upstream
right like with our config system as you
saw you should never catch a configure
at production never zero times right
everyone without guardrails like this
has pushed a configure and a prod it
just happens
right and this shift this curve shift
might not seem like a big deal
but it is because as i mentioned before
the cost massively increases at each
stage
so moving because
you know the number if you kind of like
multiply these two curves together
that's like the total number the total
amount
of productivity loss and damage as a
result of defects in your system
bending the curve like we just showed
you is a huge deal
it can represent like an order of
magnitude magnitude
improvement in both productivity because
your dev cycle is better and
business impact costs because you catch
errors at places where it's
way less terrible
[Music]
so what do you need in order for these
things to be testable
you need like kind of three things and
if any one of them aren't there you're
kind of out of you
you're kind of uh in trouble so one you
need parameterized computations
meaning that these things can be
functions you can for example substitute
sample data for real data
two you need a plugable environment you
need to be able to figure out a way
to isolate yourselves from those super
heavy dependencies
three the system itself has to be
pluggable so like stuff like
a system like daxter has a database
where you track runs and all this stuff
you know in order to run that in an
isolated environment you need to be able
to for instance cut your dependency on a
database in some cases
in order to do like effective unit
testing as an example
so and we have kind of abstractions that
try to attack all
these layers and i'm going to start to
speed up now because i just realized
that i have too much content
so we have this notion of a resource
and it's a different abstraction and
i'll talk about two things here one into
every solid we pass in this context
object
and you can think of context as like
this is the way that you interact
with the environment that you have to
interact with meaning that
you have here this this solid says that
like i need this thing called a data
lake
in order to succeed and the data lake is
you know presumably some like internal
abstraction that someone's written at
this company
to save data files somewhere
um so this solid is saying i need this
data light to succeed
right and then you always access
something like a resource off of this
context object
which means that you can change the
version of it that happens
at runtime um so
this is kind of like a built-in
coarse-grained dependency injection
system if you know that term
um if you like dependency injection this
is like a nice pythonic way
to do it if you don't like dependency
injection this feels
nothing like dependency injection but it
ends up trying to accomplish
the same thing um
so here you know based on mode i'm going
to skip this demo because we're running
short on time
but effectively from within the ui you
can
switch which version of this resource
you use and you can do the same
thing at ci cd side
so let's assume that you've used our
resource capabilities to test this thing
you have a cicd pipeline that like
isolates and cuts
some of the hard dependencies on very
expensive external resources
now we want to deploy this thing
[Music]
so if you remember that couple slides
ago i was saying that the system itself
is pluggable and i was using it to talk
about testability
but this property of the system is key
to both
testing and the flexible deployment
right we explicitly don't believe in
vertical integration
which means that you can use any
database we want you to be able to use
any execution substrate
you know um and so on and so forth the
world is very complicated and
heterogeneous and people
you know there is no one-size-fits-all
in terms of the infrastructure stack
so what we're going to show here is that
we have this local development thing and
now we're going to use the capabilities
that we've built
one instance of our stack which we have
support for
to deploy that pipeline using
help so we're going to use database for
postgres
for the component that shuffles data
between the computations
for on the user's behalf we're going to
use s3 and we're going to actually
use kubernetes plus celery as an
execution substrate
so kind of like pretty standard docker
helm stuff you have to build a docker
file
which is like your daxter dependencies
and your project
you have to parameterize this template
that we give you so you push that
you run hell and then boom you're
spinning up a cluster
um and what the cluster ends up
this is kind of what it gives you for
free i just want to talk through this
quickly because i want
i want to explain like how we think you
should run the system you know we have
this web
front end and we also have a scheduler
that can kick off jobs on a regularized
cadence
we really believe in spitting up
ephemeral compute resources that isolate
from other user processes in the system
so we spit up a kubernetes job per run
and we also
do purse and that's kind of what we call
the run coordinator
and we also isolate every single step of
execution
in its own kubernetes job and all this
coordinates via a postgres database
that's also deployed
using this helm chart so you can really
go
i mean it's definitely some work to get
this set up it's not super trivial
but yeah on like a half day knock on
wood don't
hold me account to that you can go from
like playing around this thing laptop
and doing some business logic to boom
you know pushing this to prod and really
hosting it under for real cluster
which is really exciting and then here
you get the same tools in the hosting
environment right
here you have that same configuration
editor but instead you're using it to
configure the properties of how you're
going to
do a docker image pull um in your
kubray's cluster and then you have the
same exact ops tools which are telling
you that like hey this thing executed in
this job
right it's really exciting
last we have operate so we do come with
a scheduler
or scheduling api so one of the big
things here is that you want to be able
to regularize
regularly kick off computations like say
like
every day at 3 a.m we want to be able to
execute this stuff
we leverage our config system to do this
so effectively what a schedule is
is it takes a date you run a
user-defined function and it produces a
chunk of config
to run on a specific pipeline and that's
what it does
we really like to use this config code
separation to enforce some testability
constraints you have this chunk of code
that is fixed and then you only vary on
the config
aspects this also helps like backfilling
because effectively
if you want to backfill you kick off n
things and you're
providing different dates into this
function and queuing up a bunch of runs
we have nice uis to manage this so you
can turn off and on schedules you can
see when they're last done you can get
information about them
and we also have charting and graphing
capabilities to track execution time
over time and other properties
lastly we have what we call the asset
management
um okay
thank you pete i am free to go to 955
but i will end a little earlier than
that pete i promise
um so asset management you know we
talked about data awareness
and assets are really our way of helping
out with data management at an
operational level
so what am i exactly talking about here
well
solids can also look like this so one
interesting fact here is that the core
api for a solid is actually it's a data
computation
or just a computation that yields a
stream of these structured events in the
dagster api
that inform the runtime about things
that are happening
right so what this says is yielding an
asset materialization
that is an event that indicates that it
has created some
externalized thing that will outlive the
scope of the computation
in this case it wrote to a file but it
could be anything right like
if you if you have no external side
effects what are you even doing right so
like you
at the end of the day you have to do
something and you know this is how you
track that
and then that output event actually is
like more like a signal that
it's done and here's the output and that
that's the value that will be passed
to the next solid down the chain
so quick demo on this one because this
one's really fun
i think i skipped one so go down to here
so that saved a data like thing is here
right you'll see here's
it has the required resource that it has
now if i go here and i run it
i have these pre-loaded configurations
that you can run
and now we execute this thing
give it a second here i never get tired
of looking in this gantt chart
uh if i have to be honest here
the um so
we know that this thing is yielded what
we call materialization we actually our
log viewer is nice right you can like
search for these structured events
and it says here oh it it emitted this
asset materialization and you might be
asking
what does that do well as a result of
this it actually shows up in this thing
called the assets manager
so you know it was called serials
so we can look for it and boom here it
is
and you have like this index where it
oh that was the wrong one one second i
was like that didn't fail
there we go so here we can see like hey
here's the
yeah here's this asset here's some
metadata about it here are the last runs
that touched it
and this might not seem that profound
but when you start
producing thousands and hundreds of
thousands of assets
and you have no idea where they came
from this capability of being able to
link
computations and accents and and assets
is enormously powerful we
you know the use case you should really
think about is
we have users who are allowing their
analysts
to self-serve ops wise their pipelines
so the analysts come into the system and
just like type in the name of their
database table
and then they can see oh this thing
hasn't touched in two days maybe i need
to click on that pipeline and go retry
it
and so this is a allowed effectively you
know
infrastructure developers to empower
their leaf developers to own more of the
end-to-end life cycle
and we think this is a really exciting
direction
so yeah just to summarize you know this
is kind of a whirlwind presentation
thank you for bearing with me
but you know we went through when we you
know
at least in demo form developed a
pipeline
we made it more testable um and then we
deployed to kubernetes and we're
tracking
we scheduled it and we're tracking what
assets it's created and so on and so
forth
um now what i showed you was a very
narrow
example that only involved pandas and
kubernetes
but we have an entire world of tools
that we interact with
right um like we have users who
you know are using our integration with
paper mills a great effect we have pi
spark users
we have people using snowflake we have
people using dbt we have people using
pandas
we have folks who are ingesting data
from google sheets who are
shooting out events to slack and you
know using all of our features to track
these complicated
uh interrelations and it's just like
it's too much to go into all that right
now
um but this really is turning into a
full-fledged platform
and so with that i will end the
presentation
um thanks so much for joining
you know this is an open source project
so you can go and find it on github you
can pip install you can come say hi in
our slack and ask us more questions
we have a totally new revamp doc site if
you looked at it a while ago and the
docs were a little janky
i think we've made a ton of progress on
that and
um yeah and we're about to kind of
announce a new major release next week
we'll kind of you know talk about this
thing as a data orchestrator i have a
bunch of different content around that
so i'm really excited